[موسيقى]
كان في رحله بالقطار عندما صاح الفتى
مخاطبا اباه والدي انظر الى الاشجار انها
تسير الى الوراء مسح الوالد على راس ابنيه
فيما تعال الضحك من افواه معظم ركاب
القطار مقابل نظرات الشفقه من قله قليله
بعد لحظات كرر الشاب صياحه ابي ما بال
الغيوم في السماء تلحق بنا فابتسم الاب
مجددا فرحا بفتاه هنا اقترب منه راقب
مجاور قال له لماذا لا تعرض ابنك على طبيب
جيد فاجابه الرجل لقد فعلت في الواقع نحن
عائدان من المستشفى لقد كان ولدي شبه كفيف
واليوم فقط استعاد كامل بصره لكن معظم
الركاب ليسوا على بصيره الى
العناوين المستوطنون في الاقصى وتنظيم
الدوله يفجر مسجدا في
باكستان وزير الاوقاف السوري يحتفل في
المسجد بعوده الاسد من
الصين السيسي يعلن ترشحه ويو المصريين
بتقديم البناء على الطعام ماكلش وما
نشرب رئيس اتحاد يهودي ليبيا سيف الاسلام
القذافي يستنجد باسرائيل
رئيس موريتانيا محايد بين المغرب والجزائر
ومتفهم لفرنسا في
افريقيا مقتل معوق مسلم في الهند بعد
اتهامه باكل موزه من المعبد الهام شاهين
تتطاول مجددا على الامام محمد متولي
الشعراوي غانم المفتاح معتمرا وطواف على
يديه حول الكعبه
[موسيقى]
المشرفه مرحبا فيما كانت افواج المستوطنين
تستعد لمواصله اقتحاماتها الدينيه للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك في القدس المحتله بحمايه
من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي افرغت
ساحات المسجد من المرابطين كان بعض
المسلمين حول العالم يجددون الجدل القائم
منذ مئات السنين حول الاحتفال بذكرى
المولد النبوي الشريف من العلماء من يراه
بدعه لم يشهدها عصر الرسول عليه الصلاه
والسلام والخلفاء الراشدين من بعده ومنهم
من يرى الاحتفال بالمولد جائزا اذا لم
يتضمن ما هو مخالف للدين
محمد
محمد رحمه
للعالمين رحمه
للعالمين الاختلاف على احياء ذكرى المولد
ليس بجديد لكنه لم يتحول الى عنف على حد
علمنا الا مؤخرا وعلى يد تنظيم الدوله
داعش الذي اعلن مسؤوليته عن تفجير انتحاري
قتل وجرح عشرات من المحتفلين بالمولد في
باكستان بلوشستان ترزح تحت ضربات الارهاب
مجددا والحصيله مقتل واصابه العشرات في
تفجيرين استهدفا موكبا دينيا ومسجدا في
التفجير الاول كان المستهدف وهو احتفال
بمناسبه المولد النبوي الشريف تلاه بعد
ساعات قليله تفجير ثان بمسجد اثناء صلاه
الجمعه وزير الاوقاف السوري عبد الستار
السيد حل مشكله الخلاف على جواز الاحتفال
على طريقته فراس في المسجد احتفالا بذكرى
مولد الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام لكنه
حوله ميدانيا الى احتفال بعوده السيد
الرئيس وعائلته من الصين سياده الرئيس
حفظك الله ورعاك ما كان احد يتصور انك بعد
رحله تاريخيه
[موسيقى]
عظيمه ولساعات طويله في الطيران ان نراك
وبعد ساعات فقط على وصولك في المسجد
محتفياً
واسر
[موسيقى]
الشهداء ان كان يا
رب في غيري اولى بها مني فوفقه ويسر ل ويا
رب اذا كنت انا اولى بها فوفقني ويسر لي
وعقدت العزم على ترشيح نفسي لكم لاستكمال
الحلم في مده رئيسيه جديده اذا مع اقتراب
موعد الانتخابات يه في مصر اعلن الرئيس
عبد الفتاح السيسي ترشحه لولايه جديده من
اجل استكمال الحلم ومسيره البناء والتنميه
كما قال واوصى المصريين بتقديم تطور البلد
وتقدمها على الاكل والشرب لو كان البنى
والتنميه والتقدم تثمن الجوع
والحرمان اوعوا يا مصريين ما تقدمو
اوعوا يا مصريين تقولوا ناكل احسن لكمن
تمن التقدم والازدهار للامه انها ما تاكلش
وما تشربش زي ما الناس بتاكل وتشرب ما
تاكلش وما تشربش استشهد الرئيس السيسي
بتجربه الصين دون تسميتها عندما مات فيها
25 مليون مواطن من الجوع ورغم ذلك لم
ينقلب الذين بقوا احياء على الدوله بل
بنوا بلادهم حتى صارت عظمى قال لي المجاعه
بتاعه دوله
معينه المجاعه دي قعدت من
52 ل
58 مات فيها 25 مليون بعد ما عملوا ا
ساعدوا ونظموا وقدروا يعملوا تنميه بقت
دوله عظمى اوعوا تفتكروا لما دوله يموت
منها 25 مليون من قله الاكل لا ما قموش
هدوها قاموا يبنوها الابن هو عمود التقدم
ومن يقول غير ذلك فهو جاهل او احمق ما فيش
بلاد بتطلع لقدام غير بالاستقرار
والامن يا جاهل يا احمق اللي يقول لكم
ممكن يعمل بطريقه ثانيه غير كده قالوا
للرئيس السيسي انت ايقونه مصر وبطل مصر
سيب الدوله بدل ما يقطعوك فكان جوابه انا
مستعد للموت حد قال لي انت ايقونه مصر ايه
اللي دخلك الدوله دي قال لي انت ايه بطل
مصر اوعى تخش يعني هيقطعوك يعني قلت له لو
كان تمن بنى الدوله دي مش تقطيع موتي انا
حاملها الرئيس السيسي اعرب عن حلمه بتبرع
الملايين من المصريين في مشروع بلازما
الدم الذي يحسن من صحتهم ويؤمن لهم دخلا
ماليا واوضح السيسي انه عندما حذر اعضاء
مجلس القضاء الاعلى من هدم مصر بملياري
جنيه يتم توزيعها مع ترامادول المخدر على
100 الف شخص انما كان يحذر من الفوضه التي
قد يسعى اليها البعض كما قال وانا كنت
امبارح بكلمكم بقول لكم ان اللي كانوا
بينزلوا الاشرار كانوا بينزلهم ب 20 جنيه
وشر ترامادول انا كنت مدير الاستخبارات
كنت بيعملوا ايه في البلد يكشف السيسي
ايضا انه سبق ان لام اعلاميين في القاهره
انتقدوا انفاق حكومه قطر على بناء بلدها
بدون فهم ودرايه من هؤلاء الاعلاميين
فالاعلام في مصر هاجموا ان تم انفاق 300
مليار دولار
على اعداد الدوله اعداد الدوله مش
اعداد الكاس لا فانتوا بدل ما تهاجموا
افهموا المرش شح الرئاسي المحتمل احمد
الطنطاوي يدعو الى فصل السلطات وعدم
التدخل الرئاسي بالشؤون الدينيه بقول
لحضرتك انه دي افشل واسوا سلطه في اخر 200
سنه رئيس الجمهوريه لن يكون له راي فيما
لا يدخل في اختصاصه رئيس الجمهوريه زي ما
قلت مش هيعلم المصريين يتجوزوا ازاي ولو
استحالت العشره بينهم يطلقوا ازاي ولا له
علاقه بالخطاب الديني يطوره ولا يغيره
وبالضبط وبنفس القدر رئيس الجمهوريه مالوش
انه يتدخل في اختصاص سلطه مستقله الشيخ
احمد كريمه يحرم الامتناع عن الادلاء
بالصوت في العمليه الانتخابيه خصوصا بعد
دعوه ولي الامر اليها ثم ان ولي الامر
حفظه الله دعا المجتمع او الدوله او الشعب
الى الادلاء
باصواتهم فتجد طاعته فال الابلا بالصوت
واجب يحاسب عليه الانسان ومن هنا يحرم
الامتناع عن
الادلاء بالصوت في العمليه
[موسيقى]
الانتخابيه اجمل المعارضين عند بعض الحكام
هم المضربون عن الطعام في السجون يوفرون
الاكل والشرب ويعرضون حياتهم للخطر خصوصا
اذا كانوا مرضى وكبارا في السن لكن سلاح
الصيام المفتوح يلجا اليه المعتقلون عندما
يصم السجان الاذان رئيس حركه النهضه
التونسيه راشد الغنوشي سجن في شبابه مرارا
لكن ان يتكرر الامر وفي عقده التاسع فهذا
لا يتكرر كثيرا في التاريخ الغنوشي يضرب
عن الطعام لثلاثه ايام الاستاذ رسد غنوشي
حينما علم لان معزولين السجناء السياسيين
عن بعضهم البعض ح حينما علم بان جوهر بن
مبارك دخل في اضراب قرر الدخول اليوم في
اضراب تضامني لمده ثلاثه ايام لانه اضراب
رمزي ولا ننسى الظروف الصحيه والتقدم في
السن الذي هو عليه الشيخ راشد الغنوشي ما
هو النفوذ الذي يمكن ان تملكه اسرائيل على
ليبيا ليتها ف على خطب ودها واستجداء
دعمها الطامحون من ابنائها الى حكمها رئيس
اتحاد يهودي رافائيل لوزون يقول ان سيف
الاسلام القذافي قد طلب وساطته مرارا
لعلاقه مع اسرائيل تدعم وصوله الى الرئاسه
قال رئيس اتحاد يهودي ليبيا رافائيل لوزون
ان سيف الاسلام القذافي تواصل معه اكثر من
مره عن طريق خالد بولغيب العجوري طالبا من
يهود ليبيا مساعدته في العوده للحكم واضاف
لزون في منشور على صفحته بفيسبوك انه رفض
التدخل بين سيف واسرائيل تقرير للجنه
الخبراء التابعه للامم المتحده يكشف ملامح
خطه وضعتها عائله الجنرال خليفه حفتر
للسيطره على ماليه الجيش وكل المجالات شرق
ليبيا وبمستويات غير مسبوقه يقول التقرير
ان صعود صدام حفتر كواحد من اقوى اصحاب
المصلحه في شرق البلاد يوضح كيف عززت
عائله حفتر قبضتها على القوات العسكريه
والمؤسسات المال والهيئات السياسيه موضحا
ان هذه السيطره قد وصلت الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه من قبل حفتر وابنائه خبراء الامم
المتحده لا يفقهون شيئا من الروابط
العائليه لاسره السيد حفتر رئيس اركان
القوات الجويه السابق في قوات حفتر الفريق
صقر الجروشي سبق ان شرح المعادله العائليه
اذا اردنا ان نضع المال بايد امينه هل
سنجد اكثر امنا وامانا من صدام خليفه حفتر
ام انكم ستصدق تقارير الامم المتحده التي
تتهمه بسرقه اموال الليبيين وتتركون شهاده
عمو صقر الجروشي ابناء الفريق انا عايش مع
الفريق جووا نفسي معاهم وفي المكان اللي
موجودين فيه هم ابناء رجال محترمين ويمتاز
بالاخلاق ومن ضمن انا ما دهل الا يا عمي
صقر وكلفوا بمهام خارج ليبيا مثلا نشر
السلاح من دوله معينه من نبعث اولا من
نبعث نبعث ابنا لان ابنا لن يسرق هذ
النقود وسوف ياتي بها وياتي بالسلاح في
العلاقات المتا ازمه بين الجزائر والمغرب
يعتبر الرئيس الموريتاني محمد ولد
الغزواني ان بلاده تلتزم الحياد الايجابي
في هذه المساله وهو ما حافظ عليه منذ
مجيئه الى السلطه اما في العلاقات مع
فرنسا فلا يبدو الرئيس محايدا بل انه اثار
جدلا في نواكشوط بعد اطلاقه مواقف اظهرت
تاييدا كاملا للشراكه مع فرنسا كما علق
النقاد ويقول رئيس موريتانيا ان فرنسا لم
تخرج مذلوله من النيجير بل لاسبابها
الخاصه شو يعني اسباب خاصه تغيير جو مثلا
شوبت بافريقيا اعتبر الرئيس الموريتاني ان
انسحاب فرنسا من النيجر ليس فشلا ولا
اذلالا موضحا ان باريس لديها بلا شك سبب
للمغادره واضاف في مقابله صحفيه ان
افريقيا تتوقع الكثير من فرنسا نافيا فكره
ان تكون اخفقت في منطقه الساحل واوضح ان
المشاعر المعاديه لباريس تضخمها شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي الى حد كبير مع توتر
العلاقات بين الرباط وباريس يرفض وزير
الصناعه والتجاره المغربي رياض مزور
التحدث باللغه الفرنسيه خلال نشاط عام في
مدينه مراكش يساله صحفي باي لغه تريد
التحدث بالفرنسيه ام
بالانجليزيه فيجيبه الوزير مستخدما
الانجليزيه سوف اتحدث بالانجليزيه او
الاسبانيه او
العربيه ظ تان على السؤال والجواب هما ان
الصحفي الخطير لم يقترح حتى مجرد اقتراح
اللغه العربيه اما الوزير فاجابه
بالانجليزيه ووضع العربيه خيارا
[موسيقى]
ثالثا اجرس الكنيسه تقرع معلنه نكسه اقليم
نا جورني كاربا جمهوريه ارتساخ كما يسميها
الارمن وبعد حروب متتاليه مع اذربيجان
تضيع بشكل نهائي من بين ايديهم ليس في
اقليم ناغورني كارباخ الاذربيجاني باعتماد
من الامم المتحده حتى تسلط عليه الكاميرات
بل في اقليم كشمير المنسي المتنازع عليه
بين باكستان والهند والمحتل من قبل الهند
بحسب اهل الاقليم المسلمين حملات تصفيه
وتهجير وابعاد واقصاء العلماء عن المساجد
يقولون امام كشميري يبكي لدى عودته الى
منبر الجمعه بعد اربع سنوات من
الابعاد هل يستاهل اكل موزه قتل
اكلها شاب مسلم من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
اتهمه متطرفون هندوس باكل موزه من قربان
في معبد ه هندوسي فقيدوها بعمود وضربوه
حتى الموت وقد يكون الموز بل المعبد كله
قد شيد باموال المغتربين الهندوس الذين
يعملون في دول المسلمين وغيرها تركيا ودول
اخرى تدين اعتداء جديدا على نسخه من
المصحف الشريف في مدينه لهاي الهولنديه
ومطالبه جزائريه للاتحاد البرلماني الدولي
باستصدار قانون يج المساس بالمقدسات
والرموز الدينيه اقدم زعيم حركه يمينيه
متطرفه في هولندا على تمزيق نسخ من المصحف
الشريف امام سفارات عدد من الدول
الاسلاميه من بينها تركيا وباكستان
واندونيسيا في مدينه لهي دعى رئيس المجلس
الشعبي الوطني الجزائري رئيس اتحاد مجالس
الدول الاعضاء في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
ابراهيم بوغالي الاثنين برلمانات الدول
الاعضاء الى تقديم بند طارئ خلال الدوره
المقبله للاتحاد البرلمان الدولي بهدف
استصدار قرار يدين المساس بالمقدسات
والرموز الدينيه ويجرم ان احرقوا ما في
السطور فانهم لن يحرقوا ما في الصدور هذا
ما قالته الشابه الاردنيه سند الصيداوي
عقب فوزها بجائزه دبي الدوليه لحفظ القران
الكريم رساله اوجهها الى كل العالم وخاصه
من يسيئون الى القران الكريم فلا استطيع
الا ان اختصرها بجمله بسيطه لو حرقوا ما
في السطور فلن يحرقوا ما في الصدور
والقران باق هاهنا ان شاء الله الهام
شاهين تتطاول مجددا على فكر الامام محمد
متولي الشعراوي واعتداله وترفض تقديم
سيرته بعمل مسرحي وقد ايد محبون للشيخ
الشعراوي رفضها تقديم سيرته معتبرين ان
الارشيف الفني لالهام الهام شاهين لا
يتلائم بتاتا مع الاعمال الج لليله التي
تكرم الكرام اعلنتي مع بدايه العام الحالي
رفضك تقديم سيره الشيخ الشعراوي بعمل
مسرحي لعده اسباب وابرزها افكاره المتطرفه
ولكن بالمقابل اذا بدنا نرجع لوراء
وبمقابل سابقه الك شفنا راي مختلف الك عن
الراحل وكنت نوعا ما عم مطالبه من الشعب
المصري انهم يتعلموا منه ليبنوا البلد مثل
ما عم نشوف تصريح عضنا التصريح اقول لا
يمكن اقول اتعلموا منه لا يمكن حط لنا
الفيديو فطول الوقت اقول لهم طب تعلموا من
الشيخ الشعراوي اهدوا بقى عشان نبني مصر
ونعمل لبكره شه
التناقض يا خبر اسود انا قلت
[موسيقى]
كده رجل الاعمال طلال ابو غزيله اعتدتم
على سماعه يبشر بالحروب العالميه
والانهيارات الاقتصاديه لكنه هذه المره
يروي ما يصيف ها هو بالترفع احنا بيحكوا
عنا انه راسنا يابس احكي لك بس للتسليه
كان واحد عم بيحاول يدق مسمار بالحيط ايوه
ويدخل مش قابل يدخل المسمار فراح يشوف من
الجهه الثانيه ايه موجود ايو فوجد واحد
فلسطيني ساند راسه هذا الراس الفلسطيني لا
يخترق الكلام الذي قاله السيد طلال معبر
عن صمود الفلسطينيين لكنه ليس طرفه يقول
بهي
خليك بالحروب اذا هيك الكوميديان المحترف
هو دونالد ترامب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
الذي اتقن تقليد الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
جو بايدن ترامب الذي يحاكم بقضيه فساد
اتهم بايدن بانه فاسل ويحيك المؤامرات ضده
ترامب يقضم مواصلات تقليد بايدن في
مهرجاناته
ويتلقي بكل
امتنان
[تصفيق]
لو سالنا دونالد ترامب وجمهوره الجمهوري
عن رايهم في عقوبه قطع يد السارق لقالوا
على الارجح انها عقوبه وحشيه لا تحترم
حقوق
الانسان ترامب يتوعد صوص المتاجر في حال
فوزه بالرئاسه بامات ميدانيه بالرصاص وبان
الرصاصات
عاجلهم لدى خروجهم من
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المتاجر
you
people you have 300 young people who
looking for a good future walk into a
store big department store and pillage
it and if you happen to be there when
they there they knock the hell out of
you kill you in some cases and we will
immediately stop all of the pilling and
theft very simply if
you can toot as
are
شعب اخيرا المؤثر القطري الملهم للشباب
العرب غانم المفتاح اعتمر في مكه المكرمه
ثم زار المسجد النبوي الشريف بالمدينه
المنوره وفيه التقى المستشار الملكي
الامير سلطان بن سلمان الذي اصطحبه بعد
ذلك الى جلسه ساله فيها لماذا فضل الطواف
حول الكعبه المشرفه على يديه بدل الكرسي
المتحرك شوفك زي المره المات على ايديك
اييش ما استخدمت العربيه لب اييش ما
استخدمت سبحان الله ان شاء الله ازود
العجر كثير سالني الله يجزاهم خير على
اهتمامهم ليش ما طفت على الكرسي متحرك
اساللك يا غانم اكيد لا يكلف الله نفسا
الا وسعها وكان في وسعي اطوف بيدي بفضل من
الله بصراحه استحيت من ربي اطوف على كرسي
والله منعم علي بقوه يدي تدرون اجمل واروع
شعور لما لمس كفي ارض الحرم الطاهره اشعر
كل جسمي كان كهربا دخلت فيه وقوه سرت
بعروقي كنت قريب من ارضه وروحي في سماه
شعور جميل ما اقدر اوصفه حسيت نفسي اني
اطول الطوافين قامه مع صغر جسمي حسيت جسمي
كمل فقدت احساسي بالبشر ما كنت اشوف حد
كاني اطوف حول الكعبه بنفسي كنت مطمئن ما
كنت خايف من حد يدهسني لاني كنت في حمايه
رب العالمين ثم امن الحرم اللي ما قصروا
[موسيقى]
معي ختاما لكل الرعاه كلاب تجمع لهم
الماعز والاغنام وتسوقها الى حيث يريدون
يكشر الكلب عن انيابه القاطعه في وجه
الدواب بفعل ارهاب لا تقوى على مواجهته
رغم انها قطيع كبير يقب كلب واحد خدمه
لسيده الذي سيبيع الخراف لمن
ياكلها الى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ه